[Musik]
in einem hotel in düsseldorf wird ein
türkischer mann festgenommen mit waffe
und munition
sein ziel erdogan kritiker die situation
für die kritikerinnen und kritiker
erdogans in der bundesrepublik ist auf
heimliche angst wer sich in deutschland
gegen den türkischen staatspräsidenten
stellt muss mit gefährlichen
konsequenzen rechnen
ich glaube ich würde den letzten schliff
verbrauchen aber wer so etwas tut so
etwas rechnen traurig ist es dass das
land wo ich liebe liebenden vergöttern
weil ich ja alles verdankt habe ich mich
alleine lässt wie weit gehen erdogan und
seine akp
insiderberichten
methoden der mafia die gegenseite
erpressen erschrecken die eigene macht
demonstrieren
zdfzoom fragt wie groß ist der einfluss
von erdogan in deutschland
was ärgert java im letzten sommer in
deutschland erlebt hat machte ihn
fassungslos
den journalisten droht in der türkei die
festnahme er hatte geheime dokumente
über waffenlieferungen aus der türkei
nach syrien veröffentlicht vor fünf
jahren ist er deshalb mit frau und
tochter nach deutschland geflohen in
berlin fühlten sie sich zunächst sicher
obwohl es die eine oder andere drohungen
gegen ihn gab im juli passierte es dann
er wurde in seinem haus angegriffen
[Musik]
sie haben die gunst der stunde genutzt
als unsere deutschen nachbarn zwei
häuser weiter vom einkaufen zurückkam
sie haben sofort einen fuß in die tür zu
ihrem vorhof gesetzt meine frau saß bei
mir wir haben einander angeschaut sie
haben den ersten und zweiten vor hoch
schnell überquert die kamen weiter in
unsere richtung dann kam alles schlag
auf schlag dann haben sie zunächst
angefangen mit üblen beleidigungen
anschließend haben sie geschrien du
wirst aufhören zu schreiben und dann
haben sie auf mich eingeprügelt
der angriff der heute nur ein paar
sekunden einige gezielte faustschläge
mit der aufforderung du wirst aufhören
zu schreiben in türkischer sprache der
journalist erlitt einige platzwunden und
wurde im krankenhaus behandelt
das lka stellte ihn unter polizeischutz
und ermittelt in deutschland doch rk
gera hat am dialekt erkannt dass die
täter aus der türkei kommen müssen er
verdächtigt offizielle stellen aus der
türkei zuvor hatte er über korrupte
verstrickungen innerhalb der regierung
berichtete er selbst stand schon auf
mehreren todeslisten wurde er wegen
seiner berichte vom mit dem türkischen
geheimdienst bis nach deutschland
verfolgt
das türkische agenten in deutschland
aktiv sind liegt ein ereignis wenige
wochen später nach ein hotel in
düsseldorf
ein mann mit türkischer
staatsangehörigkeit checkt ein er ist
ein moment unaufmerksam
ein hotelmitarbeiter bemerkt dass er
eine pistole bei sich trägt und
benachrichtigt die polizei
im zimmer des mannes findet das sek
später eine schreckschusswaffe und
scharfe munition
der generalbundesanwalt übernimmt den
fall und erklärt dazu es liegen
anhaltspunkte dafür vor dass aig im
auftrag des türkischen geheimdienstes
verdeckt informationen über im raum köln
wohnhafte anhänger der sogenannten
grünen bewegung sammelte um sie an den
türkischen nachrichtendienst im ead zu
übermitteln
die türkische regierung verdächtigt die
gülen-bewegung hinter dem putschversuch
2016 in der türkei zu stecken seit fast
fünf monaten sitzt der mann nun in
untersuchungshaft bei ihm wurde auch
eine sogenannte todesliste gefunden
solche listen kursieren immer wieder im
netz darauf oppositionelle kurdinnen und
erdogan kritiker der deutsche staat
unternahm lange nichts gegen diese
listen warnte nur die menschen die
darauf standen
wir fahren nach weilheim in oberbayern
und nehmen die frage mit ob der
türkische geheimdienst tatsächlich
erdogan kritiker in deutschland bedroht
erich schmidt eenboom ist der
bekannteste geheimdienstexperte
deutschlands er hat bis heute jahrelange
kontakte zum verfassungsschutz und kennt
die aktivitäten verschiedener
geheimdienste in deutschland darunter
auch den geheimdienst des türkischen
staates den m die situation
ist außerordentlich ernst die
bedrohungslage umfasst ja nicht mehr nur
drei briefe e-mails repressionen gegen
verwandten türkei weil es besteht das
risiko der schweren und schwersten
körperverletzung und ich will auch nicht
ausschließen
das fanatisierte einzeltäter
die durch die türkische propaganda vor
allem im internet angestachelt werden
zum mord und totschlag greifen zumal es
überall im internet und nicht nur auf
twitter
todeslisten gibt
erdogan gegnerinnen und gegner vor allem
journalisten geraten dabei oft in den
fokus des mbt des türkischen
geheimdienstes
bekannte
staatsterrorismus dabei tritt der mit
nicht direkt selbst in aktion sondern er
verlässt sich auf 1 gruppe das sind
nämlich die grauen wölfe akp und im hb
nahestehende organisationen
als graue wölfe werden rechtsextreme
gruppen in deutschland bezeichnet in der
türkei werden sie durch die ebenfalls
rechtsextreme mhp vertreten die mit der
erdogan partei akp als koalition die
regierung bildet die ideologie der
grauen wölfe ist faschistisch sie wollen
ein großstädtisches reich sie sind teil
verschiedener vereine und verbände geben
hier oft den ton an
[Musik]
erdogans einfluss in deutschland ist ein
heikles thema das bundesinnenministerium
und der verfassungsschutz lehnen unsere
interviewanfragen ab im dezember 2021
findet die innenministerkonferenz stadt
ihr fragen wir den niedersächsischen
innenminister boris pistorius hat der
staat türkische rechtsextreme und den
geheimdienst mt zu lange gewähren lassen
wir haben die todeslisten generell jetzt
unter strafe gestellt das ist schon mal
ein wichtiger schritt wehrt listen
erstellt oder verbreitet macht sich
strafbar das ist neu und notwendig
gewesen
ansonsten werden wir natürlich sehr
genau hinschauen und die
polizeidienststellen das kann ich für
niedersachsen mindestens sagen sind
überall ansprechbar für diejenigen die
sich bedroht fühlen oder es sind und
auch die verfassungsschutzbehörden
schauen sehr genau hin welche aktiv ist
ob es nun der mrt oder andere da schauen
wir schon sehr deutlich hin und agieren
darauf
nun hat es tatsächlich situation gegeben
wie ein angriff auf einen journalisten
zu hause und festnahme von mutmaßlichen
agenten mit waffen und munition
warum wird da so viel zugelassen ich
würde erstmal widersprechen dass da viel
zugelassen wird taten passieren
straftaten geschehen verbrechen
geschehen das ist immer so gewesen
unsere aufgabe als sicherheitsbehörden
ist es sieht dann schnell aufzuklären
und die täter den gerichten zuzuführen
beziehungsweise soweit es um
ausländische die nation geht dann auch
zu intervenieren das ist dann sache der
bundesrepublik die bundesregierung aber
dass wir dinge zu lassen dem würde ich
widersprechen der staat setzt auf
strafverfolgung im nachhinein tut aber
vorausschauend wenig gegen die
strukturen die den boden für solche
straftaten bereiten erdogan betreibt
weiter den macht ausbau von
antidemokratischen organisationen diese
sorgen dafür dass der einfluss der
erdogan partei akp auf die türkische
community bestehen bleibt das netzwerk
ist weitreichend zum teil wird es vom
verfassungsschutz beobachtet neben den
bekannten moschee verbänden die tiptop
und militärisch gibt es noch weitere
kultur vereine und verbände
[Musik]
dabei geht es auch um wählerstimmen aus
deutschland für erdogan sagt
politikwissenschaftler kemal basa
[Musik]
welches interesse hat denn die türkische
regierung an der türkischen community in
deutschland sind die mobilisierung
spielt insofern eine wichtige rolle dass
man bestimmte politische einflüsse auch
über die community geltend machen möchte
wenn man druck auf europa ausübt wenn
man zum beispiel bestimmte sogenannte
innenpolitische themen die in der türkei
stattfinden auch hier weiterleitet weil
wir hier auch viele geflüchtet haben aus
dem kurdischen raum so dass bestimmte
polarisierungen ganz klar die in der
türkei stattfinden auch hier weiter
forciert werden hier auch eine gewisse
mobilisierungs ebene stattfindet bei den
letzten wahlen haben auch besonders
viele junge menschen aus deutschland die
erdogan partei akp gewählt auch sie
unterstützen den autoritären und
diktatorischen ansatz aber warum wir
haben einen präsidenten der ganz klar
auch als rächer der verschiedenen
unterdrückungsmaßnahmen der türken
auftritt und auch mal einfach waren
minute sagen kann und sagen kann hier
zeige ich mal flagge und damit auch bei
vielen türkeistämmigen als rächer für
ihre verschiedenen erfahrungen
benachteiligung erfahrung des gremiums
erfahrung worauf tritt
ihre heimat finden dabei viele in einer
organisation die mittlerweile sehr weit
verbreitet ist mit mehreren hundert
standorten und allein in deutschland mit
über 15 regionalverbänden
wir haben eine große lobby organisation
die der akp nahe steht und auch
vielleicht diplomatische flügel der aqap
ist das ist die idee die sich früher
oecd nannte und was ist eure aufgabe die
aufgabe und dieser strukturen ist es
natürlich hier auch eine lobby struktur
aufzubauen und damit auch lobby
organisation aufzubauen die
lobbyorganisation idee befindet sich im
permanenten austausch mit ankara im
letzten sommer lud der staatspräsident
seine europäische gefolgschaft in die
türkische hauptstadt ein die gezielt auf
seiner offiziellen homepage und im
türkischen fernsehen verbreitete
motivation rede macht deutlich welche
bedeutung die idee für ihn hat
[Musik]
wir sehen in der union der
internationalen demokraten idee das
wichtigste mittel für diesen heiligen
und schwierigen kampf
also eure mission ist keine gewöhnliche
aufgang sie ist äußerst bedeutsam und es
geht darum in den ländern in denen ihr
euch befindet den geist der solidarität
gut zu begreifen und eure rechte dort zu
erlangen so wie diese rechte auf
höchstem level zu verteidigen
um mehr über die idee zu erfahren fahren
wir nach hamburg die idee wird seit 2017
vom verfassungsschutz beobachtet in
seinem letzten bericht heißt es zitat
gegenüber der öffentlichkeit gibt sich
die idee betont gemäßigt und ist bemüht
die verbindungen und
abhängigkeitsverhältnisse zur türkei
herunterzuspielen
wir treffen will entgegen er ist
mitglied der spd aber zugleich auch
aktiv in der idee im sommer 2000 21
gelang ihm ein publizistischer erfolg
ein meinungsbeitrag in der wochenzeitung
die zeit darin schrieb er die
türkeistämmigen abgeordneten des
bundestages seien türkei und
islamfeindlich deshalb könnten sie die
türkische community nicht repräsentieren
konservative muslime wie er hätten keine
chance in der deutschen politik auf sich
aktiv war und als ich den bürgern den
landtag kandidieren konnte dann waren
als eine frage ob man frank hof trägt
und ob ich regelmäßig
leitungsteam und seid ja das war schon
team
über die ich angesprochen wurde und
ob damals hat auch mehr eine frage wie
gesagt dass ich meine wer ferien und
begabte politik geben aber ich bin nicht
der türke den man sich wünscht er ist
denn der türke denen man sich fühlt das
wäre jemand der zum beispiel nicht
diese frau ein kopftuch
der sich formiert hat und sollte
vielleicht auch eine deutsche frau
deutsche mann hatte und das war auch für
mich der ausschlaggebende grund damals
dass ich nur eine aktivitäten damals in
der partei was nach unter gefangen dafür
intensivierte er seine aktivitäten bei
der lobbyorganisation idee
2020 trifft er erdogan persönlich und
dieser schlägt ihn als neuen
vorsitzenden der vom verfassungsschutz
beobachteten idee vor danach twittert
bülent gewinn wir danken unserem
türkischen staatspräsidenten
später wird ein anderer vorsitzender aus
dem umfeld der grauen wölfe bülent
gewinn bleibt trotzdem ein
einflussreiches mitglied
es kommt immer wieder der vorwurf dass
sie ein erdogan lobbyist sind dass sie
politik für die akp hier machen dass sie
im prinzip hier stritten ziehen und die
akp politik in die deutschen parlamente
tragen wollen als spd-mitglied was sagen
sie dazu sollen wir jemand nachmachen
ich bin kein ehrlich ich habe allein
getroffen ich würde das ja nicht und ich
fand ja auch vieles was er natürlich
mache gut er hat das grund und
sozialprodukt der türkei die vielfach
dem durchschnitt eine brutto ihre
jährliche wachstumsrate von 5 prozent
hat wer große infrastrukturprojekte
jemand versucht das kurdenproblem zu
lesen und dann gab es diese putz
versucht und dann auf andere ein paar
andere pool und das führt dann zu
sicherheitsproblemen der türkei geführt
sie haben gerade aufgezählt was sie an
der johann gut finden aber wir müssen
das doch auch als schmerzhaft empfinden
dass er im prinzip die pressefreiheit
abgeschafft hat und den rechtsstaat
christian friedrich
also auch das würde ich sehr relativ
sehen wo wir würde ich einen gerechten
und abgeschafft hat
versuchen wir in der türkei eine auto zu
klauen wo sie gegenüber fürchten sie
bilden egal wer rechtzeitig für hotel
gut okay es mit dem auto klauen okay
aber ich meine das gibt es ja leute die
sitzen im gefängnis kriegen keinen
prozess sitzen vielleicht auch
unschuldig im gefängnis manche leute
hier in deutschland haben angst in die
türkei zu fahren weil sie denken sie
denn da verhaftet weil sie einmal in
facebook post gemacht haben von drei
erdogan
dass ich bin ich kenne viele leute die
die eltern kritisch sind und wer auf den
trick alien ich kenne keinen der
festgenommenen beispiel auch das
wiederum so eine eine annahme die mit
der realität nicht überein
stimmt realität ist dass immer noch ca
120 deutsche in der türkei festgehalten
werden auch aus politischen gründen
ungefähr die hälfte sitzt im gefängnis
der rest unterliegt einer ausreisesperre
die idee finanziert sich offiziell durch
mitgliedsbeiträge doch schon lange
besteht auch der verdacht dass geld aus
ankara fließt mädchen kühlen kathi
strukturen in deutschland aufgebaut seit
ein paar jahren wird er verdächtigt
illegale geldflüsse aus der türkei
organisiert zu haben
das thema wurde letztes jahr wieder
aktuell als videos des mafiapaten setup
egger auftauchten darin behauptete er
selbst in diese geschäfte mit der akp
infrastruktur in deutschland verwickelt
zu sein
in deutschland gibt es doch diese
vereine das input die jungs wie maxi mit
den kühlen sportlich ihnen geld zukommen
zu lassen ich habe ihnen geld auf die
hand geschickt
mafia geld für deutsche vereine über
diese korrupten verstrickungen
recherchierte r kagawa
deshalb wurde es auch in deutschland
gefährlich für ihn
[Musik]
erdogan versucht wie in der türkei die
dynamiken in europa lebendig zu halten
aus diesem grund kann er insbesondere im
umfeld von wahlkämpfen die atmosphäre
der gewalt zwar nicht so adäquat wie in
der türkei aber durchaus auch in
deutschland aufrechterhalten
wir wollen verstehen wie das system
erdogan außerhalb der türkei
funktioniert und treffen einen der es
wissen muss der ehemals hochrangige
diplomat will nicht erkannt werden um
sich selbst nicht zu gefährden er kennt
die türkische regierung umstadt
präsident erdogan aus nächster nähe nach
dem putschversuch 2016 geriet er in den
verdacht ein erdogan gegner zu sein und
floh nach deutschland
das sind die methoden der mafia die
gegenseite passmann erschrecken die
eigene macht demonstrieren das hat die
türkei getan hat gesehen dass es
fruchtet und das nichts dagegen
unternommen wird die türkei hat gesehen
dass sie nicht blockiert wird und dann
hat sich damit einfach weitergemacht
weil sie davon profitiert hat wie zb
der journalist deniz yücel der fast ein
jahr lang in der türkei im gefängnis saß
war für die türkische regierung eine
gute gelegenheit ihre ganze macht zu
demonstrieren
auch der angriff auf ärger könnte eine
ähnliche machtdemonstration sein
bewiesen ist das nicht doch allein die
möglichkeit sollte anlass sein eine
angemessene reaktion zu zeigen so der
ehemalige diplomat
man hätte erwartet dass fünf oder zehn
politiker zu erkennen und sich vor sein
haus stellen dort eine erklärung abgeben
und sagen so nicht so was würde dann nie
wieder geschehen
der ehemalige diplomat erzählt uns auch
noch dass die türkische regierung seit
ein paar jahren vermehrt auf propaganda
im netz setzt ziel auch die jüngeren
generationen stärker an sich binden
werden auch in deutschland kp
propagandisten in den sozialen medien
bezahlt oder wie gefördert
definitiv werden sie gefördert das ist
ihre arbeitsmethoden deutschland ist
einer ihrer als orte istanbul ankara
izmir adana und dann kommt schon an
fünfter stelle deutschland einstimmen
depot für die akp deshalb wird er
selbstverständlich besonders viel
propaganda betrieben
[Musik]
und tatsächlich finden wir viel
stimmungsmache gegen deutschland im netz
ein beispiel von vielen mikro kanälen
sind die post einer jungen frau namens
es mappus sie will sich mit uns am
flughafen köln treffen da sie gerade
wieder auf dem weg in die türkei ist wir
wollen sie auf ein video ansprechen was
uns besonders aufgefallen ist denn in
diesem sommer nutzte sie die katastrophe
im aartal um gegen den deutschen staat
zu hetzen
das ist hier das europa das ihr so
beneidenswert findet und der
wirtschaftsstärkste europäische staat
ist deutschland
sozialstaat
das ist der sozialstaat das was ihr hier
im hintergrund seht das ist der
sozialstaat
mehrere regierungsnahe türkische medien
verbreiten das videomaterial für sie ein
gefundenes fressen um angebliche
fehlentwicklungen in deutschland und
europa zu zeigen an diesem nachmittag
erfahren wir nicht mehr ob es markus
theil einer propaganda kampagne ist denn
nach einer stunde warten müssen wir
feststellen trotz fester verabredung
kommt sie nicht
klar ist auch solche videos spalten und
verunsichern die türkische community
eine die damit zu kämpfen hat ist daniel
kittel tepe
bundestagsabgeordnete der spd sie ist
unterwegs im kreuzberg wo sie geboren
und aufgewachsen ist sie möchte dass die
türkeistämmige community ihre politische
heimat in deutschland findet so wie sie
selbst bei vielen hier ist es auch
passiert trotzdem merkt sie immer wieder
sie steht in konkurrenz zu erdogan
wir haben ja in deutschland auch fehler
gemacht in den letzten fünfzig sechzig
jahren es hieß immer wir sind zu gast
özil gehen und über die ganzen jahre gab
es keine richtige politik sie für diese
menschen ausgerichtet war man hat sie
vernachlässigt nicht anerkannt nicht
wertgeschätzt und das kommt natürlich
irgendwann zurück und diese menschen
fühlen sich
wertgeschätzt durch erdogan der ihnen
immer wieder sagt wir sind stark wir
haben was zu bedeuten wir haben was zu
sagen in der welt global nah und jeder
sucht eben auch sein
für johnson käsetheke ist erdogan ein
hindernis denn der hat schon dazu
aufgerufen etablierte parteien wie die
spd cdu und grüne nicht zu wählen für
ihn sind sie feinde der türkei
als volksvertreterin bezeichnet und
bedroht wurde sie auch schon stand
zeitweise unter polizeischutz das ist
nicht gerade hilfreich wenn ein
staatspräsident
mit
propagandamitteln aber auch mit parolen
und einen gewissen hetze hier die
menschen
aufhetzt aber auch spalte dadurch wir
sind auf dem weg zu einem dem ehemals
erleben musste dass diese spaltung auch
zu gewalt führen kann in salatic ist als
boxer gewohnt auszuteilen kürzlich wurde
der erdogan gegner bei einer
joggingrunde von drei männern
angegriffen und verprügelt nicht das
erste mal direkt danach stellt er seine
reaktion ins netz
schämt euch ein sportler der die
türkische fahne vertritt ein
landesverräter
in heimtückischem hinterhalt anzugreifen
ich bin mittlerweile nicht traurig
aha
der box champion ist getrieben davon
sich ständig gegen erdogan zu
positionieren im netz und im wahren
leben deshalb wurde er sogar schon von
erdogan persönlich angezeigt wir treffen
ihn in königsbrunn bei augsburg trotz
vergangener prügelattacken bei seinem
heutigen kampf will er wieder ein
statement gegen erdogan setzen
ist der einfluss von der akp von
erdogans partei hier in deutschland so
groß natürlich sage ich die osmanen
würde dieses milley glich was die alles
dafür täten was die vier organisationen
ich sage mir die jugend die verpassen
gehirn möchten wann kommt deutschland
sowie kann deutschland solche vereine zu
lassen wo man genau weiß dass diese
kinder rekrutiert werden dann ist doch
deutschland gehen aus und mit schuld wir
sind doch schon mit schuld daran dass
die jungs in meinem alter rassistisch
gegen deutschland eingestellt weil die
knete verein kam unser lernen land und
bekam keinen job wir haben die buden uns
reingefressen er trägt ein t-shirt mit
der aufschrift die türkei gehört nicht
der akp so beginnt sein kampf schon vor
der halle
er hat die doppelte staatsbürgerschaft
boxt aber trotz seiner erdogan kritik
unter türkischer flagge
[Applaus]
[Musik]
mittlerweile liegen in der türkei drei
haftbefehle wegen präsidenten
beleidigung und bedrohung gegen ihn vor
in salla rick hat viele kämpfe gewonnen
aber auch island immer wieder verloren
den gegen den türkischen präsidenten
sogar hier in königsbrunn nach seinem
sieg wird unser weg vom moderator
aufgefordert sich nicht kritisch über
erdogan zu äußern es seien zu viele fans
des präsidenten in der halle und es
könnte stress geben
alaric ist sauer weiß aber der moderator
kann nichts dafür
das klima von promoter bevor
krass und jetzt frage ich mich was habe
ich bloß gesagt ich sage meinen
36 40 jahre besser die ständige erdogan
kritik wird für ihn zum problem die
veranstalter wollen einfach keinen ärger
[Applaus]
alles unter vertrag ist fast fertig und
da kommt anders ich habe zuviel
drohungen erhalten
da stell mal vor die stadtmusiker ist
menschlich lobte jetzt mal einfach
selbst was ich will
trotzdem stand bleibt eins kann man mir
nicht sagen wann schritt abgewichen die
fans stehen auf seiner seite aber immer
mehr einnahmequellen brechen weg neue
sponsoren zögern bei einem sportler der
sich ständig politisch äußert seine
gegner wiederum werfen ihm vor es ging
ihm mit seiner erdogan kritik allein um
for motion
und alaric fürchtet den türkischen
geheimdienst und fühlt sich von
deutschland allein gelassen wir fragen
beim bayerischen innenminister herrmann
nach ob der staat weiß wie groß das
netzwerk des türkischen präsidenten
mittlerweile in deutschland geworden ist
wir spüren schon dass
sich überall auf der welt natürlich hier
die türkische regierung wirkliche
sicherheitsorganisation
nachrichtendienste unsere alter
entsprechend unterwegs sind das ist
integrationsfeindlich das hemmt die
positive entwicklung war uns und es ist
im einzelfall eben in der lage auch
durchaus eine gefahr eine bedrohung für
einzelne
mit bürgerinnen mitbürger die der
türkischen regierung missliebig sind
insofern müssen wir hier auch von
unseren deutschen sicherheitsbehörden
schon ein plan blick darauf haben doch
wenn es immer wieder angriffe gibt und
der türkische staat mit so vielen lobby
organisationen in deutschland vertreten
ist bleibt die frage ob die bisherige
bundesregierung zu wenig getan hat
ich glaube dass insgesamt die haltung
der deutschlands unter war denke ich
auch kein großer unterschied zwischen
cdu csu spd fdp und so weiter
festzustellen dass wir dadurch für eine
insgesamt sehr klare haltung hatten und
auch damals ja noch mal klar sagen ja
wir müssen gegen erdogan eine klare
position beziehen ohne dass langfristige
verhältnis zur türkei kaputt zu machen
ich hoffe sehr auch auf eine seite nach
erdogan und da müssen wir insgesamt
wieder ein möglichst partnerschaftliches
welt das mittelstück entwickeln
warten auf die zeit nach erdogan
spekulieren auf dessen mögliche abwahl
im jahr 2023 ist das der richtige weg
wir fragen bei dem geheimdienst experten
schmidt-eenboom nach ich halte diese
strategie des aussitzens für völlig
illusorisch
selbst wenn es nach erdogan 2023 eine
andere türkische regierung ohne akp ohne
mhd geben wird dann hat sich in der
bundesrepublik doch dieses repressive
schattenreich gebildet das besteht auf
grauen wölfen aus diplomaten aus front
organisationen und das wird man nicht
einfach aus der welt schaffen können
sondern es bleibt ein stilles
gefährliches netz in deutschland
wer sich in deutschland kritisch
gegenüber dem türkischen
staatspräsidenten äußert lebt gefährlich
erdogan hat über jahre ein großes
netzwerk aufgebaut kritische stimmen
gegen ihn werden nach wie vor
eingeschüchtert bedroht und es kommt
häufig zu übergriffen der deutsche staat
muss endlich handeln neben der
strafverfolgung muss es auch um
strafvereitelung gehen nur auf ein ende
erdogan zu warten reicht nicht